All right, thank you very much.
All right, this is my story.
I was dating this girl like two years ago.
Been dating her for like eight months
since she wanted to meet my parents.
She was really giving me shit,
like, how come I haven't met your parents?
And, you know, I always just, I never liked,
you know, I never brought anybody home
to meet my parents, I was like 30 years old.
Never met, brought anybody home.
Never, I didn't ever like meeting people in general.
God, I didn't want to meet her parents.
I always hated when you had to meet,
like, you know, go out with somebody,
you gotta like meet their friends and shit.
You know, sitting at the table trying to be interesting.
I usually end up just sitting there staring at
like mashed potatoes or some shit.
So she's like, you know, how come, what's wrong with you?
You know, how come you don't want to meet me, you know,
bring you home to meet your parents?
I started thinking about it, like, you know,
not only had I never brought anybody home,
you know, a girl home, and I was 30 years old,
I'd never brought anybody home.
Even like back in like first grade,
like second grade, I may have friends and shit,
I just never brought them home.
So I started thinking like, you know,
how the hell did that start?
You know, as you know, so we're basically driving up
from New York to go to my house to finally meet my parents.
And I remember like, I think it was like
when I was first grade, we used to have a bus stop,
and it was like right out in front of my house,
so my parents used to always be arguing.
My dad was like a maniac, you know,
God damn fucking bitch, you know, just total psycho.
My dad was like a complete psychopath, you know,
like his nickname in my house was called The Thing.
Because that's what he was, he was like,
he was this fucking thing that like, if he wasn't around,
we'd say, dude, is The Thing home?
You know, if he wasn't home, he could chill.
He was just like never in a good mood.
So one day I'm down at the bus stop,
there's like, you know, 10 other kids down there and shit,
we're all like in first grade, second grade,
third grade waiting for the bus.
And it's like towards the summertime,
my parents got like the windows open and shit.
So I can start to hear like an argument start,
and I'm like, well, what the fuck do you mean,
you didn't know?
And I'm sitting there like, please,
please let the bus come, please, for Christ's sake.
And all of a sudden, you're a goddamn fucking bitch,
yeah, screaming and shit.
And I remember just looking at all the other kids' looks
on their faces, like, I guess, you know,
this is like way before cable,
so most kids never even heard curses.
They couldn't believe it.
And I was just, that's when it really hit me,
that man, my family's really screwed up.
And I started going over other kids' houses
and their parents seemed to get along, they were like, cool.
And so the whole time I'm driving back,
my girlfriend coming up, all this stuff is like coming back
and I'm thinking, and I'm like really getting like,
oh, like I'm a six-year-old kid again,
like getting all nervous, like how my dad is gonna like act,
because it's like embarrassing, you know?
I mean, I remember like he was one of these dudes
where like, I don't know, he's just always in a bad mood,
like if he tried to like teach you something,
he'd say it once, and then when you didn't get it,
he'd just say it louder and louder.
And I remember six, he's going, this guy, he's retarded.
Like I remember we got a dog
and he's trying to teach his dog how to sit, all right?
It's a dog, it doesn't speak English,
and he's sitting there going,
and he's like, all right, sit, this little puppy, sit.
Sit down, you're gonna get over there
and you're gonna sit down.
Dog's sitting there like walking around like peeing,
like what the fuck is wrong with this guy?
And that was like his thing, man,
everything like in my house,
my parents, they were like ridiculously strict.
They had all these stupid rules,
like I remember they had like this one rule,
whatever you didn't eat for dinner,
they would just like wrap it in cellophane
and you had to like eat it the next morning for breakfast.
And there's like, everybody's sitting there
eating their like pancakes and waffles.
You're like eating like cube steaks and shit.
Dad be going, come on, eat it.
I don't want to eat it.
Eat it!
So I'm like driving back and that's all I'm thinking,
it's like, God, this guy's just gonna
completely embarrass me.
And I don't know, like it's just,
I just felt weird, like my family was like,
like the, you know, most famous like loving,
like build somebody up, like our family was just,
all of us just like ripping somebody down.
Like, I think the worst thing he ever did to me,
this is the one that really kind of made me like
the anxious, like worrisome person that I am.
I remember, it was right around Christmas.
I was really thinking this,
because I was driving this girl up for Christmas.
He, he was giving me shit one day.
He always hated when I was joking around.
I think making my mother laugh somehow was,
I don't know, bug him or whatever.
So he kept giving me shit.
Come on, man, you know, keep joking around, you know,
giggling all the time, you're acting like a little girl.
And I'm thinking like, cause he's always fucking with me,
I'm going, God, here's a new angle.
You know, you're asking for a football for Christmas,
you're acting like a little girl,
what the fuck's wrong with you?
And I'm just sitting there going, geez.
So like two weeks later, it's Christmas time,
I got like four brothers, right?
We always sneak down to go look at the presents.
So we go downstairs, right?
There's all these gifts down there all wrapped,
we're all looking to see who got what, you know?
There's all these little tags, to Ed from Santa.
You know, be like, you know, to Bob from Mama Dad or whatever.
And I'm sitting there.
Just wait a second.
So I look, in like the middle of the tree,
I see there's a doll.
And I'm thinking, I got four brothers,
what the fuck is there, a doll sitting here?
And I remember just looking at this thing,
you ever see like those Spike Lee movies
where like the background moves and the character doesn't?
You just, it's like one of those deals.
And I look up at this doll, right?
And it says, to Bill from Santa.
And I'm like, what the fuck?
Guy got me a goddamn doll.
He came downstairs and he's laughing and shit,
and he's making me take a picture.
I'm like six years old and crying and stuff.
And I'm thinking of this shit,
as I'm pulling into the driveway,
I'm like freaking out,
because I'm finally gonna bring somebody home
to meet this fucking maniac.
And I'm telling her, you know,
I don't know how this guy's gonna be or whatever.
So we're walking to the house, you know,
it's like candles and shit, you know, Christmas tree,
it's all real nice, dim lights and stuff.
She comes in, she meets my dad,
and the dude is like totally normal.
After me building this guy up the whole ride back,
he's like fucking like, you know,
that dude from Leave It to Beaver.
He's like the nicest guy ever.
He's all cordial.
And I remember I'm just getting like pissed at the guy.
Go, why isn't he being a dick?
And she's sitting there and taking me aside,
going, he's the greatest guy.
I can't believe you're saying all that stuff.
He's such, you know, he's smart, he's intelligent,
he's so interested in what I have to say.
I remember I was like, I was so pissed at the guy.
I mean, I really hated him when I was growing up.
To the point, I remember one time he went out on the driveway
and he's running out to his car,
and he slipped and fell and broke his shoulder.
And at that point, me and my brother
so fucking hated this guy.
When he came to the house,
my mother's like taking care of him.
We snuck out the back door
to look at his footprints in the snow
to see where he slipped and fell.
And I'm telling you, we were laughing our asses off
at this guy.
You're right there, right there, that's my brother.
Fuck, why couldn't I have seen that?
So,
so he ended up being like the sweetest guy ever
and there was nothing anxious about it.
I like worried about it for like,
I don't know, from the beginning of the time,
dating girls was like 15
and I just ended up feeling really stupid.
And I was kind of pissed.
I was just looking at the guy going,
oh, why the fuck couldn't you have been like this
20 years ago when I needed him to be like that
rather than being the way he was?
And that's my story, thanks.